this is Apple's brand new M2 Max MacBook
Pro with the 38 core GPU and so is this
the only difference is the size in fact
they are spec the same with 32 gigs of
RAM and one terabyte of SSD and the
question I'm gonna answer in this video
is do you sacrifice any performance by
going with the smaller 14 inch model now
what I do want to mention is that with
the 16 inch you're paying 200 more and
you are getting something that you can't
get on the 14 inch model and that is
high power mode and the crazy thing this
year is that Apple actually allowed high
power mode to give you higher clock
speed as you can see right here 3.68
gigahertz single core compared to 3.49
limited on the 14 inch and to save some
time I've already ran the geekbench
benchmarks as you can see right here the
multi-core performance is around 15 000
the same across both of them however
because of the higher clock speed we
have 2050 29 single core on the 16 inch
compared to 1953. now is that going to
make a difference in the real world well
I did test speedometer 2.1 which is a
browser Benchmark and it's basically the
same it seems like it's going down to
the same clock speed when web browsing
for some reason so it's not really
utilizing the full 3.68 and now to save
time I also tested metal in geekbench We
have basically the same 85 000 points
but of course we do know that
geekbench's metal test doesn't fully
utilize the chips because it has some
gaps where it's not running in high
power full performance state so because
of that let's switch to something better
which is gfx bench metal we're going to
test the 4K and 1440p Aztec Ruins High
tier off-screen tests and I did open up
acetop so I can measure measure the peak
wattage to see if there's any
differences let's get started holy moly
I cannot believe this difference this is
without any thermal throttling fans
nothing the 16 inch is actually 16 and a
half percent faster in terms of the FPS
and the 4K test and 20 faster in terms
of 1440p imagine that this is without
any thermal throttling at all that is
really weird almost like the 14 inch is
instantly down clocked I honestly did
not expect to see 20 more FPS like this
is a gaining workload if anybody does
gaming the 16 inch for 200 you're
getting 20 higher performance very
impressive I actually want to check out
acetop to see the peak wattage here oh
look at that
58.8 Peak wattage on the MCU Max 16 inch
but on the 14 it was limited to 55 so it
couldn't push out as much wattage and
now before I get into the real thermal
throttling overheating testing with
cinebench R23 I'm do you want to run
Wildlife extreme which is an unlimited
off-screen test where I can actually
monitor the frequency so let's go ahead
and turn this on and see if we have any
caps let's watch this so pay attention
to the GPU usage right here and the
clock speed 13.98 we have for the 16
inch so that's full maximum clock speed
and look at that we have the same 1398
on the 14 inch no difference whoa wait a
minute look it's actually down clocking
itself during the test you saw that
little Spike you could see on the 16
inch you have all solid bars right here
that's 100 but look it actually down
clocks slightly during the test that
basically confirms some sort of
throttling that apple is putting on the
14 inch that they're not on the 16 even
without overheating with high temps it
did clock the GPU down for some reason
on this 14 inch and I do want to mention
that low power mode is off nothing like
that it's plugged in no issues at all
and we are seeing a drop in score 132
2.7 FPS compared to
150.7 on the 16. that's 13 and a half
percent more FPS with no throttling due
to heat at all something else is
limiting it alright so that was very
interesting to see but let's switch over
to the CPU side with cinebench R23 I'm
gonna do a single multi-core test first
to kind of establish our Baseline for
both of these machines and wow even just
on this test I already say the 14 inch
heating up a lot faster 93 degrees
compared to 88 on the 16 inch it's
definitely heating up quicker and yep
the fan did just turn on 2400 RPM fan is
still off on the 16 inch and 100 degrees
Celsius on the 14. that was pretty quick
before even finishing one run but it
didn't matter for the CPU We have
basically the same score 14 700 on both
of them and now let's do the 10 minute
throttling test I'm gonna open up MX
power Gadget to monitor the clock speeds
of everything you can see right here
frequencies we have the ecore hours 2.42
on both 3.26 for the performance course
and the GPU is not really being used so
it doesn't matter you can see the
wattage right here 35 Watts 35 Watts for
the whole package CPU right there 35 we
have the temps and the utilization which
is not going to matter for this test
holy moly guys 105 degrees Celsius 106
right there it's heating up insanely
fast and wow the difference in fan
speeds is insane holy moly 5200 RPM
already on the 14 inch while this one's
basically idling look at that you can
see the green bars barely above idle
where we're literally 5700 RPM on the 14
inch and I can audibly hear it quite
loudly now and whoa I did not expect
this look the 14 inch allows the fans to
ramp up to 6800 maximum that is insanely
fast I don't even think they did that
before so Apple knows this thing's
heating up really quick if they're
giving that big of a maximum all right
guys I've got to give props to Apple
because they were able to contain the
heat before it hits 108 degrees Celsius
which is usually where you see the
thermal throttling happen and the clock
speed go down on the CPU they ramped up
those fans really quickly so good job
apple on that fan curve and now it has
it under control but wow the 16 inches
so impressive 102 degrees Celsius the
fans are still at 2000 RPM it's handling
the heat so much better than the 14. and
now that we're eight minutes into the
test I do want to look at the actual
chassis temperatures and wow look at the
14 inch 47 to 48 degrees Celsius right
there on the display because it does
have vents right behind behind the hinge
so as pushing a ton of heat out now it's
cooling down a little bit let's look at
the 16 inch
wow 42 and it's actually on the hot spot
it is handling the Heat
like crazy so much better but wow it
didn't even matter look at that the 14
inch actually got four more points than
the 16 inch so no difference it's able
to keep the performance good job on that
14 inch but now let's do the ultimate
unrealistic stress test this is not
going to happen in regular use where
it's going to do 100 CPU and 100 GPU at
the same time with Wildlife extreme the
stress test so let's start that up and
then let's go over here and start the
multi-core cinebench at the same time
and oh my goodness uh oh I can't believe
it look at that oh the performance cores
on the 14 inch are clogged down to 1.27
gigahertz compared to the actual 3.26
that you're actually supposed to get
even the 16 inch is throttling right now
holy moly what the heck this does not
make sense we're sitting at 107 degrees
Celsius on the 16 inch but the 14 is
only 90. it's clocking the CPU down like
nuts 1.2 gigahertz are you kidding me it
is literally capping the wattage look
only 30 Watts on the entire package
compared to 52 on the 16 inch 18 what
what is going on 60 watts 62 Watts on
the 16 inch on under 30. literally apple
is capping the 14-inch model like nuts
this is pushing power this is giving us
good results I don't know what apple is
doing with this 14 inch capping the
processor like this now one thing I do
want to mention this year with these M2
Pro and Max models is that the heat
sinks are smaller compared to the
previous generation but let's do another
thermal camera comparison holy moly 53
degrees Celsius on the 14 inch even
though the chip temp is low wow 52
degrees Celsius and then on the 16 we
have 46. wow that is a huge difference
this thing is hot to the touch holy moly
that finally explains why we're seeing
88 degrees Celsius on the chip because
they are throttling it so badly because
it's heat soaking it anyway all right
the 16 inch model finished first we have
a score of 11 344 so it is down Thermo
throttled compared to the Baseline that
we did before Oh My Gosh the 14 inch
just finished I cannot believe that
score 4
553 it lost over half of its performance
in this extreme Thermo throttling test I
can't believe that level of throttling
absolutely insane and as it stands right
now just comparing these two scores the
16 inch is two and a half times higher
in terms of cinnamon score which is
Bonkers and keep in mind we still have
Wildlife extreme running so I'm gonna
let this run and then we're gonna
analyze the performance charts for the
graphics as well well and there you go
the 20-minute stress test is finished
and wow look at that the 16 inch is
incredibly stable 99 stability which is
basically the difference between the
best Loop score and the lowest so
19965 for the best and then on the 14
inch
94.2 stability so big drop there and
even the best Loop score is lower than
the one on the 16 inch 18
353 which makes the 16 inch nine percent
faster in terms of this test while being
two and a half times faster in cinebench
so huge difference in terms of thermals
now I know that was an extreme and
unrealistic test but keep in mind that
there are tasks out there that use both
the CPU and GPU and I'm actually going
to be running one of them in terms of
Final Cut Pro video editing so if you're
one of those people that does have a
task like that the 16 inch is looking a
whole lot more promising but now let's
get rid of the benchmarks and let's get
to some actual real world productivity
work and the first one is gonna be
blender 3D rendering I have the BMW
project open right here so let's go
ahead and hit render image and wow I was
not expecting this six hit is finished
in 22 seconds compared to 31.5 on the 14
inch that's basically a third slower
compared to the 16 inch model wow let me
tell you this 16 inch is getting more
and more appealing as we're getting into
this testing now opening up the uh party
tug project and I am noticing it load
faster on the 16 inch which is a great
sign and let's go ahead and render party
talk they're done and wow we have
basically the same score a minute and
four seconds on both this is still
Cycles so I don't know what difference
there is compared to BMW and now I'm
curious to see how this affects photo
editing because Lightroom classic now is
using a lot of the GPU so I have 50 42
megapixel Raw photos right here as you
can see we can kind of go through them I
don't expect any difference whatsoever
in terms of smoothness in the real world
while actually editing them but I do
want to test out exporting so I got my
timer ready let's go ahead and Export
look at that they both finish at the
exact same time 44 seconds no difference
whatsoever for this Lightroom classic
export and now let's move on to video
editing in Final Cut Pro now in terms of
editing regular and common formats like
h.264 and hebc which most people are
editing I don't expect any difference at
all because it is encoder and decoder
limited and just to prove it to you guys
I'm gonna run an export test right here
with my timer and as you can see they're
both basically neck and neck and if we
look up here to the CPU and GPU usage 15
for CPU 40 for the GPU that means that
they are not being pushed because it's
waiting on the actual media engine so
there's no way we would see any
difference between these two there you
go a minute and 13 seconds exactly on
both of these and realistically you
should expect the same exact results
with prores as well because these chips
have prores encoders and decoders so to
find a difference between these two we
have to find something that isn't going
to be limited by the media engines and
does push the CPU and GPU and that's why
we have this right here 8K Canon R5 raw
video put into a 4K timeline this is
extremely stressful on the CPU and GPU
let's actually run it as you can see
it's dropping frames all over the place
look at that CPU and GPU are basically
getting pushed like crazy 80 on each on
both of these machines this is a hard
test and it actually is realistic
because some people do work with this
footage and they like to have MacBooks
and for you guys this is a test for you
so let's run this export I actually have
MX power Gadget because I'm curious
about the throttling as well and look at
that right away we are getting
throttling on the 14 inch 2.3 gigahertz
on the performance core while the 16 is
staying at 3.27 and same thing for the
GPU 1.38 1.39 on the 16 1.25 1.19 on the
14. so both the CPU and GPU are already
throttling and wow I didn't even notice
the 16 inch 108 degrees Celsius fully up
to the temperature limit already and
keep in mind this is not some fake
Benchmark this is a real test while
already the 16 inch is basically maxing
out its fans while we have about 3 600
on the 14 inch about halfway we're about
three minutes in and so far the 16 inch
is handling this beautifully I'm barely
seeing any throttling at all essentially
no throttling on the 16 inch while the
14 is getting just crushed the
performance cores are down to two
gigahertz GPU is down to 1.2 gigahertz
so crushed in terms of throttling and
you know what let's just throw in a
final thermal camera test right here we
have the 14 inch you can see 50 degrees
Celsius right over there and whoa 43 44
on the 16 inch once again even in a real
workflow like this a big difference in
temps and there you go I have the
results wow that's incredible the 16
inch finish in 6 minutes and 41 seconds
the 14 inch finished in 9 minutes and 28
seconds that's two minutes and 47
seconds longer that is worth two hundred
dollars for the 16 inch if you're doing
high-end work like this that's mixed CPU
GPU that is worth it definitely get the
16 inch in this case because wow that
difference is huge so with all that said
and tested let's answer the original
question what do you sacrifice by going
with a 14 inch M2 Max 38 core over the
16 inch well in those extreme thermal
throttling tests like that video editing
test we just did you're sacrificing
quite a lot of performance due to
Thermal throttling you're also
sacrificing the blender 3D rendering
task like we saw in BMW taking a lot
longer on the 14 inch without any
throttling going on and especially for
that gaming test gfx bench we saw up to
20 higher FPS on the 16 inch and to
think that we just had the difference
just because of the size 200 more that
is well worth it but let's be real let's
calm down I'm gonna try to be a little
bit more calm this year in reality both
of these are extremely good they're more
than enough for 95 of people out there
but if you care about having the most
performance you can get go with the 16
inch or if you have a psychological
thing where you don't want to feel like
you're getting Limited in any way like
you want to have the maximum performance
then go for the 16 inch but if
portability matters more to you and
you're okay with letting a little bit of
performance go the 14 will be just fine
don't worry about it forget about seeing
those numbers just go for that if
portability matters more to you but in
my case I like that display that's a
nice big display the extra battery life
the extra performance that's what I
would go with especially for the 200
difference so that is my take hopefully
you enjoy this video and if you did go
ahead and click subscribe check out more
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
foreign